I'm not so worried about artificial
intelligence and I'll tell you why the
reason relates to this famous gentleman
Albert Einstein he said that somebody if
he was falling if he was in an elevator
and the cable broke God forbid and the
elevator start to fall that person would
experience no gravitational force it's
called the Einstein equivalence
principle he called that the happiest
thought of his life how do you expect an
a computer or an artificial general
intelligence could interpret these two
phenomena freef fall the visceral human
centered experience of freef fall A and
B have a happiest thought for me that
gives me great comfort because it really
is occurring in the human mind the human
brain another thing that is of infinite
complexity and possibly forbidden to our
understanding behind an ignorance
Horizon like the big bang how can a
computer experience a visceral sensation
if possible and how could it ever
associate happiness with it